she's holding a knife being young and
gay in Russia can be dangerous Emily so
they're learning to defend themselves so
for example I'm here me she's holding a
knife the breaking point for Yulia was
the murder of a young gay man in
Volgograd he was killed because they
thought he was gay and they thought it
was bad and that's why I see these
murders I see this you know consequences
and I was telling people hey guys we
definitely should go to the process
because if we can't defend ourselves
nobody will help us their fears are not
unfounded
the teenager in the middle has been
lured here for what he thinks is a first
date with a man he met online the group
filmed themselves as they surround and
humiliate him promising to show this
video to his friends anyone who wants to
speak out about gay rights in Russia
during the games is meant to come here
to the official protest zone in an empty
park under a motorway bridge 20
kilometers from the Olympic Village you
know no one we spoke to wants a boycott
of these games they respect the right of
the athletes to compete but they just
want their voices to be heard and for
people to understand what's happening
here president putin dismisses all
criticism insisting gay people should
feel relaxed about coming to these games
but in the same breath urging them to
leave the children alone
gay rights campaigners here aren't you
it's the children who need help children
404 was set up to help young gay people
online this poster says we exist
it's finder is now being prosecuted
under Russia's new anti-gay law accused
of spreading homosexual propaganda this
cruise will be tightened and tightened
even further I'm scared to even think of
what this can lead to I'm not waiting
for anything good from our future a
strong project will keep going and if
they find me I will try to pay it
about their big values within the
Olympic movement the campaign group
all-out released this video they're
calling for a day of global action today
to stand together for Olympic values and
against discrimination of any kind Katy
Stallard Sky News Sochi